yeah uh how did it start who is Hans
Neiman who's Magnus Carlson how did it
start there's three games it started in
Miami yeah a good a good background
story is Magnus Carlson is the arguable
greatest player of all time very close I
would say to to Gary Kasparov world
number one for now over 10 years with
the top of this game you think like
close to the top of his game right now
after the most recent thing yes
I think he has The Uncanny ability of
top athletes to absorb the [ __ ] and
show oh yeah Dad's home now you know
yeah run I was only trying 70 before
that you know and and I think that's
what he I think I really think that's
what he sure I was in awe I
if Magnus is playing in a tournament yes
it's good for views to put him in my
YouTube thumbnails and make the video
title about him if he does something
brilliant but I was legitimately just
blown away it wasn't even wasn't farming
him for Content it was this is
unbelievable what he's doing to people
and he has a point to prove
Hans is a I believe he's 19 years old
right now he's an American
I don't know if Prodigy is necessarily
the right word prodigies you you know
their prodigies from very very young you
don't in chess you don't become a
prodigy at 18.
but he was always a good Junior player
he was always a very unique character
like I met Hans when he was 11 12 years
old he was this little kid just trash
talking Folks at the Marshall chess club
and he already had a reputation
literally like he had a reputation with
with counselors with like and the truth
is I was similar I was kicked out of
Chess Camp by one of the best chess
Grandmasters of all time Arturo Yusuf I
was in a chess Camp when I was nine
years old what'd you do I was just an
[ __ ] yeah I was too strong so I
helped other people with other work you
let your ego shine that was a kid I mean
I wouldn't well you know not every kid
let's say you go shine but some do oh
yes you did uh Hans does I think there's
interviews when he's young yeah or like
he's kind of yes talking [ __ ] but it's
entertaining yes when I try to stay away
from is just
yes I let my ego shine but I don't think
I even knew what any of that was when I
was younger yeah so it's just sort of I
was just that was just a loud boisterous
kid from a household where I wasn't paid
attention to because I had three of them
yeah
so I just was like here's where I'm
gonna show up and get my attention and
or through your soup of he's a great
great man I drove that man crazy he was
like top five in the world at some point
in the 80s and 90s he said it's either
me or this kid oh wow that's what you
really got to yes he said I'm not gonna
come back and teach camps unless it's
Mir and I remember like going through
this I have very vague Distant Memories
of this my dad calling apologizing yeah
and make you feel good that you got to a
Grandmaster no I feel horrible I felt
guilty I feel guilty my whole life about
I very rarely feel proud of bad things
or I showed them yeah even things it's
good it gets to the point you feel
guilty about things you didn't do that's
what that's when your brain really goes
crazy yeah I'm with you on that
so okay so you can relate to this yes to
Young Hans and he
was like in and out of Chess this is
what I remember he was around the rating
of 2300 and I remember looking at some
of his games in a tournament in
Philadelphia
and I was like
there was some game that he played and
he didn't know the opening it was like a
London which is a very popular opening
some theoretical and I looked at him
like
whoa he didn't know that okay that's
crazy and then I just kind of walked by
and I saw him in a tournament a few
months later and he did something very
rare where in an open tournament not a
tournament of 10 players or Everybody
Plays everybody open tournament
randomized pairings depending on how
many points you have he played nine
grand Masters which is crazy that means
he was performing so well so
consistently that was where he got his
first IM Norm it's like oh here it is
here comes that like boom of a young
player where he gets mature he gets back
into the game and he gets stronger
I don't follow a whole lot pandemic
happens and he starts streaming a bit
and he's he's boisterous he's he's kind
of like loud he's talking trash and he's
gaining rating constantly he's just but
so are a lot of people so you don't
think much of it and then now you can go
play over the board again live
tournaments face to face as opposed to
online events and he's like I'm gonna go
to this tournament I'm gonna win it I'm
gonna get my last gem Norm
many does
and then he's like all right my goal is
this rating by the end of this year he
gets it he just demolishes absolutely
everybody and you're like over the board
over the board like this guy's for real
there's a lot of people like that if you
look at the top Juniors of the world
it's crazy Ali has a faruga 2 800.
Vincent kymer 2700 a bunch of kids from
India 27 some other age you're younger
usually one or two years younger maybe
maybe a little older by a year but it's
just this wave and you're just high for
the guy yeah like this this is [ __ ]
awesome like we got we got a young
American guy who [ __ ] talks every time
he's on camera and he beats everybody he
plays
but then you start hearing sprinkles
here and there maybe in some stream I
think you he doesn't he doesn't get to
play on chess.com anymore yeah like
chess.com doesn't put that badge there
on the account sometimes sometimes they
just tell the player listen we know and
the player's like all right you got me
and that's it there's no conversation so
there's like these sprinkles but
people cheat online especially when
they're young it's very you know it's
very captivating it's a very nice thing
to do just to be clear I mean just make
explicit that the accusation and I think
it's proven but they're still being
shady about it to the degree is done is
that he cheated on chess.com when he was
12. 12 and 16.
that's what he says but he admitted to
but right now chess.com put out a
statement and now Magnus put out a
statement as well saying
we think it's more than that and yeah
I've talked to Danny because he wants to
come on the podcast which I'm gonna
actually
kind of interested in I think he's a
cool person
um and they're also doing some really
interesting anti-teaching stuff which to
me from an algorithmic perspective is
interesting but he is also
the man like there's always in every
field there's the institution
so he represents the institution because
Chester calms institution it's like in
the Olympics it's the ioc it's like I'm
I'm you don't have to be I have to be
careful
um you know and just feed a is the
institution okay yeah budgets.com
they've outgrown way more people
actually know chess.com way more people
know me way more people know Hikaru it's
one of the reasons it's actually where
the power lays who has the most power
interesting yeah chess.com has the most
power which I don't know maybe you and
her car would do no um the stair public
opinion you know
it's a very good question I have to
think with my evil cap now what would
happen if I'd rather you have the evil
cup than Hikaru because I feel like he
would really you know the power
absolutely if the two of you ruled the
world it'd be a problem
you mean side by side or uh yeah it
would be like yeah as Rivals there would
definitely be a war it's one of the
reasons I would I would I would not just
box him
do you guys how much do you like each
other I mean do you admire each other as
fellow
um I'll tell you how I feel it's so
entertaining
um well we should finish Magnus hunts
yes yes I know I feel like just inside
we don't want to talk about it because
it feels like it's been talked about so
much I'm trying to give up for you just
remember I for me it's even it's much
less yeah and for the and that's the
very easier listener zero yeah yeah so
like a like Rogan asked me like so wait
what's this I know I heard him even
talking what's this chess you know Joe
talked about the Indonesia thing yeah he
said in some super random small thing
and that was a very funny moment I told
them about this drama a few weeks ago
and then he's like yeah this is
interesting because the anal beads is
that possible is that good yeah I think
it's possible
um I don't remember how drunk you were
but so even you know he's curious he
doesn't really know but anyway cheating
when he was 12 when he was 16. as he
said he admitted yes to cheating online
line when he was 12 and 16. yes but for
timeline's sake let's just let's just do
it this way he has a lot of
over-the-board success but nobody really
talks about the online cheating stuff
it's sort of
kind of kept low-key a couple hundred
people maybe a couple thousand people
which sounds like a lot but it's not
because there's millions of viewers know
about this it's generally kept kind of
low-key because historically
if you cheated online as a teenager
you're not cheating over the board it's
not possible you will get caught nobody
has ever attempted it we've had over the
board cheaters but not at the ultra
Elite level
and so what happens is
they played this tournament in Miami
and the first day Hans loses three
nothing
this is important because on the very
next day it's not like Hans was
destroying every Everything the second
day of the tournament he sits down game
one versus Magnus in their best of four
and destroys him
like he destroyed him
made it look like I was playing in
magnus's shoes you know the level
difference it wouldn't have even leaky
it wasn't close
of course we can argue it might be
because of the maybe Magnus knew
something ahead of time there's
obviously the psychological element not
not important Hans leaves they say
interviewer says
Hans Yesterday by the way horribly
phrased interview question he goes he
goes Hans
yesterday was a terrible for you
and today you start with a masterpiece
what do you have to say
just speaks for itself walks away yeah
argue you can argue it's cringe you can
argue I thought it was cool and then the
guy then keeps asking a question with
his arm extended because he's so shocked
he doesn't know what to do like he
didn't even occur to him how ridiculous
it looked to be asking and then
not only does Hans come back and loses
the best of four he loses like two more
games or maybe three I think he loves
the next three games
he then proceeds to lose every single
best of four match for the rest of the
tournament he ends with zero points and
a prize money of zero dollars they put
up the graphic
and he put Neiman zero I think he got
some minimum right
so
it's like wow this is like insane this
guy comes out with this crazy interview
and in my recap videos I was like the
next time Hans has success he has to
stay away from the cameras don't let him
talk just don't let him talk it's gonna
be bad luck and I'm joking around like
next time he plays it's crazy he's gonna
that was that was their kind of first
interaction there they also
there were some photos they were having
fun playing on the beach I don't know
where they had a chessboard on the beach
chess players or something yeah so they
were still getting along I guess so yeah
it's interesting because I talked to him
at that time would he have mentioned
something right I wonder what he would
would have said if I asked him about
Hans because that was clueless did
anyone care no no no no no nobody no no
how this is not a super known entity
right he became yes much more known he
became probably a top five all-time
popular chess player in the last three
weeks yeah so it's it's not it wasn't it
wouldn't even be a worthy question no
I'm not you you don't know maybe Magnus
already kind of knew a lot of the top
players it seems are coming out now and
saying we are ready we're suspicious it
seems like Magnus might have known but
maybe not enough to address it uh he
still might not be willing to dress it
yes yeah but anyway so like so so yeah
so totally horrible tournament
performance after correct uh after Hans
then the annual tradition of the St
Louis tournament happens which is a
strong field of players first for a fast
tournament rapid and Blitz
and a classical tournament
and the classical tournament is the
singfield cup it's the it's named after
rexingfield billionaire chess
philanthropist
uh and it's like Saint Louis chess club
yeah it's a prestigious place it's a
whole host of a prestigious tournament
Hall of Fame is there for chess
I don't know if it's the Us hall of fame
or worldwide Hall of Fame but yeah it's
it's the two countries play chess I
didn't they do but you know we will I I
don't know whose determine is where the
Hall of Fame gets to be if we say it's
the Hall of Fame okay yeah one day some
other part of the world's gonna be like
actually it's over here so
basically what happens is we have a
field set for the singfield cup
set it's the top 10 players in the world
some can't make it so okay you get
number 11 in there or something
one of them can't come because of
something related to coronavirus it's
not it's not
now we're going to get little asterisks
on Spotify because it was mentioned uh
get more info about coven 19. uh so I
don't know why he couldn't come but he
couldn't come okay something happens he
can't make it Hans Neiman is the
replacement yeah
at the time we didn't know this but now
weeks later we knew Magnus wanted to not
play
this is very important back then we
didn't know
apparently some other top players also
didn't want to play
they also were suspicious they also
wanted increased anti-cheating measures
which by the way in chess are dog [ __ ]
like do you give this little metal wand
and you put it on the little the ears
the body and there's apparently an
argument a micro earpiece would not be
caught something in the armpit vibrating
would not be caught something in the
shoe they don't make the players take
their shoes off because it's too elitist
how you're gonna make players take their
shoes off that's oh my God but if these
things are out there
or if anything was inside any other
orifice correct yes I have to bring that
I mean I mean to be honest yes that that
is very truthful uh so if nothing else
this podcast is about honesty and truth
so I have to be complete and
transparency so what ends up happening
in the same field cup is Magnus ends up
still playing but the anti-cheap
measures are not introduced
so the first few games Hans has a very
very impressive first round game against
levonne aronian one of the best players
in the world
okay draw he was pushing draw second
game demolishes like a like a top player
Mommy dear crushes him dominant opening
but not like a perfect game you
understand like it was it was uh he made
some inaccuracies here and there and he
ended up winning in a complex game
because game three happens versus uh
versus Magnus
and not only does he beat Magnus with
the black pieces
he dominates him from start to finish
so in the opening Magnus played
something with white that he had maybe
played once or twice before there was
some big debate about it I'm not going
to get into it basically a very Niche
small thing that
just he had never played in maybe a long
game before
with some sprinkled in venom that might
get Hans off guard Hans proceeds to play
like the first 15 20 moves absolutely
perfectly
and then converts the game into a
slightly better end game
and squeezes magnets to death basically
beats Magnus with black which nobody had
done in years the same way Magnus would
have beaten other players
then he goes and gives this interview
which
where he claims that he had looked at
those first 15 20 moves right before the
game basically he got lucky didn't he
say he looked at something some very
similar no he it was it was either
similar or or literally that exact
variation which is possible I've done
that before one of my best ones of my
life that morning I went you know I'm
not prepared what if my opponent plays
this Queen's Gambit accepted variation
and I literally learned the first 12
moves he didn't know move 12 I killed
him okay like it just happens yeah
unfortunately when you combine that with
other small elements of the interview
and now there's body language experts
going all on this
it was odd he gave an interview
afterwards explaining his uh explaining
various details of the game but not
really explaining them that's the thing
the standard chess player interview is
you sit down you go
something about the opening something
about not oh yeah I looked at this right
before the game and then you explain
various Symphonies and and compositions
of variations things that went through
your head things you were evaluating but
hans's interviews are different so
everything about him as the chess player
already is different and his interviews
are extremely strange and also different
yeah that's fine
but not when you combine it then with
the world champion withdrawing right
after you beat him
and ghosting the entire Chess World
yeah so there's a for people who haven't
listened to it there's a kind of
sloppiness
to the way he analyzes
the game
like he's like oh yeah yeah like it's
very um because it's very obvious like
what do you mean yeah just completely
winning here well yeah I'm completely
winning here and it's like uh I uh yeah
I just played perfect I play Perfect
like there's a sense of like
but it also doesn't for me again a very
outside spectator it doesn't raise any
red flags that's just his personality he
seems to really like to talk this way
and plus this could be crazy uh but do
you have a sense that he's more of an
intuitive player versus like he's just
not the kind of person that analyzes
really well is it or is that a
ridiculous notion well let's put it this
way
to succeed legitimately because
obviously this is a cheating scandal at
the end of the day at the 2750 82800
level the upper echelon of chess
you cannot be an intuitive player
you can be a little bit more intuitive
than a calculator and a concrete
evaluator of positions meaning if I give
you five seconds to play a move
you're going to choose the best move
quickly those people are generally
better at fast time controls but you
have to be good at everything
and what raised red flags in this
interview
was the fact that it was different than
every other interview any human being
ever gave at that level of Chess
particularly after beating Magnus for
the first time as a teenager which is a
very small group of people and so that's
where it got
weird and the very next day Magnus
withdraws from the event
Chess World lights completely on fire
for multiple weeks and he also tweets
right now yes that's the resignation no
resignation the sweet was I'm
withdrawing for the tournament in St
Louis I've always enjoyed playing here
and I will in the future and then it's a
clip of Jose Mourinho I cannot speak I
choose not to speak if I speak I'm in
big trouble I don't want to be in big
trouble yeah and that one that's some
people
nuts but people said it's not even a
cheating insinuation which was one of
the theories another theory was someone
in team Magnus told Hans what Magnus was
looking at and that's why Hans learned
those first 15 moves which is so [ __ ]
stupid because Magnus knows like five
people
not in not in his life but his team is
fine that's very close in that group
right but to The Outsider that sounds
like a very legitimate Theory how could
how else can you explain Han said he
knew before the game what was going to
happen Magnus senses a mole he's not no
by the way just just uh just so uh I
know like if that was forget the
cheating aside if you knew doesn't
matter how the opening your opponent is
going to do they prepared is that a
significant help to you
if that opening is ultra sharp and
requires basically the game to be on the
knife's edge yeah yes meaning one
mistake from can be fatal
because then you can look up what the
engine says you can know everything you
can know all the possibilities so even
if your opponent goes off that engine
path you will know how to punish it in
this case
what happened basically was Magnus
played a line that if completely
optimally punished would have given Hans
a slightly better position and that's
what happened but then he also
demolished him in that later phase of
the game
yes and then okay so uh Magnus designs
go silent the Chess World goes crazy uh
what else is interesting in that period
of time hans's fourth round game of that
tournament
right after beating Magnus was also just
absolutely genius
just an absolutely brilliant game which
he failed to win
but then after that game he also gives
once again another interview
where he's like this game was absolutely
Genius Like This was I was just killing
him from start to finish and like there
was a moment he
literally says oh yeah I just gave him a
piece like a full piece which is a
substantial advantage to the other side
and he starts explaining
why
the position is winning but in words not
in chess moves not in specific concrete
chess moves which is the way you're
supposed to if you understand the
position right so now there's this new
Theory that's being cultivated if it's
the interviews are going to be used as
the evidence
and Beyond round four
he just played like a a good Grandmaster
and he lost two or three games maybe
maybe two games and he drew the rest so
he didn't win again
like he beat the first two out of his
first three games he beat mamajara if he
beat Carlson
and he also went on the attack himself
he that was when he publicly admitted to
cheating in an interview that he gave to
the St Louis chess club that's when he
said he's never cheated over the board
then he said
chest.com has banned me from the global
Championship which is what I was invited
to to play privately they banned me they
didn't even ban me publicly and then he
said and Hikaru is uh is is is on Twitch
every day you know saying things about
me this and that
and since then
nothing tournament finishes somehow I
don't know how we got to the end of the
tournament I really thought that it was
going to get called off
but tournament ends Hans hasn't said
anything since then so has he still said
what was the last time that was the last
tweet that he said September 7th says
Hikaru wants to play the victim
something like this they face each other
again recently when was it what was that
they played in the online event of this
uh meltwater Champions chess tour
which is a 16 player tournament where
everybody plays everybody first
and after 15 games
the top eight make a knockout bracket
and Magnus played the game there was
obviously a lot of hype prior
for what was going to happen in this
game Magnus plays one move
and resigns
actually I imagine he didn't want to
play one move I imagine he would have
resigned the game as it was starting but
I think some websites don't let you
resign before you make one move because
then the game isn't counted yeah so I
think he didn't want to play at all but
he played one move and that made it even
more epic I suppose
and he resigned and that was that was
that like so you still you you lose that
game counts right you lose the rating
all these online events unfortunately
don't count for any sort of rating uh
but on the tournament yeah you play one
move yeah so he resigns and then how
does the tournament still work out is it
determined already over so he made the
eight as Magnus still made the the top
eight it was round five
or like round six or something so it was
halfway through the preliminary stage
yeah it affected his standings
but then after resigning that game
Magnus finished first uh in the bracket
in the preliminaries and then he won the
entire event there was a chance that
they were going to meet in the final
but Hans lost in the first round
against the Vietnamese strong player Le
Quang Liam
and then Magnus gave a short interview
to the live broadcast
where he said he would give a statement
at the end of the tournament and then he
did he gave a statement at the end of
the tournament
and now here we are the only other thing
missing from this is the
very intense scrutinization of all those
over the board games that I mentioned
earlier
that Hans dominated in so people are now
going through all of his games that he
played in tournaments
and they're analyzing them with engines
and they're saying he played
exceptionally well and the debate is was
he cheating or was he way too good
already but underrated
because he could have had incubated
knowledge so he could have not played
for a couple years was 2700 level but
was playing people who were 24 2500. ah
well well over the I I see so not just
over the board with the top level people
like Magnus but over the board in
general uh yes before he got a chance to
play in these super tournaments against
the best players in the world he had to
go to Europe he was the most active
chess player in 2021 and he was quite
dominant yes I think he played more over
the board games than any player in 2021
or 2022 I think it's 2021
and yes I think his rise was steeper
than everybody maybe with the exception
of well there was a faruga who got the
2800. see I'd like to believe because he
he talks about being very
he just became obsessed with chess
and I like stories like that
I like stories of um the underdog
especially with the Scarlet Letter of
having been a cheater in the past
I like the idea of somebody who is
flawed
psychologically and ethically and just
just the full fascinating personality
and this somehow just becomes obsessed I
mean similar to Bobby Fischer is also a
tortured Soul also flawed also just
chaotic all over the place you could see
Bobby Fischer being somebody that might
cheat when he was 12. right on the
online chess right like if it existed
yeah actually I think in some podcasts
like small chess podcasts I don't wanna
I I like Ben Johnson so I I'm
apologizing for calling it small but
compared to like let's say Alex Friedman
podcast uh it's uh what's what's it
what's this podcast it's it's perpetual
chess it's kind of like oh I love
Perpetual chess what are you a joke
really dare you cop yeah all right
um I'll show you because it does a lot
of it talks
it makes me feel special let me see
where is it Perpetual chess
um he does like improver series yes yeah
yeah yes yes yeah he's great Ben I
forgot I'm so horrible with names his
name is Ben Ben Johnson yeah it is Ben
Johnson that's right yeah the Perpetual
chess podcast that's amazing see legs
when even individuals like myself who
might have a large audience when I look
at you you're at a you're just at a
different level I don't expect you to be
listening to chess podcasts during the
day just imagine you're generally doing
something to change the world or into
some Visionary people well I should say
it you know I've been running a lot and
I listened to podcasts a lot because
they're such
I love human beings excited about stuff
that really energizes me and
um I've listened to a bunch of Chess
podcasts I I'm really energized by your
love of Chess
um I really like yeah sorry I forgot his
name but Ben Johnson I love it when he
talks to Grandmasters I love this when
he talks to the the the the the regular
folks for the improvers like to see how
they balance life and chess and all that
kind of stuff he's just pretty good at
it he's like super excited and they talk
about books yeah and they get excited
about different books yes I mean it it
also gives me a sense
of
where the Chess World is from a
different perspective is like people
studying chess
like what they get excited about how
difficult it is
um yeah it's nice to get a sense of the
community the language that's used
because I did want to have a bunch of
conversations
um
with folks about Chess because I think
it's a beautiful game and I I think it's
a beautiful community so that's that's
one of the podcasts I listen to so yeah
anyway it's great anyway you were saying
why why'd you bring him up yes great
podcast great podcast I only reason I
thought of it uh and I used the word
small no disrespect Ben is because even
that episode which he did with Hans like
it was a small episode it wasn't seen by
mass audience of Chess and you did an
episode Hans recently or no some time
ago yeah and in that episode Hans very
openly is like Bobby Fischer was
misunderstood and he was my idol
oh I said a couple of things like that
and strong Hans isn't intense guy like I
when I listen to Hans I get a little
anxious I just he brings out some sort
of disturbance in my ecosystem yeah it's
just I I can't really pin him down to
like what what's going on there yes as a
person who's trying to read people yeah
um it's difficult like I can I can this
is the dark aspect he could be both the
genius of Bobby Fischer and a genius
cheater and you could see like there's
something chaotic about him which makes
him very appealing in that way yes so
right now late September 2022 the
current
environment is such that Hans hasn't
said anything in weeks
and
people are sort of
dissecting every bit of circumstantial
evidence that they can and they're
trying to present the case
I don't even know to who ultimately
I guess it would be the feed a cheating
anti-cheating commission or whatever it
might be to you essentially I mean to
people with the platform it could be to
present convincing evidence to where the
the people
the people are convinced of one way or
the other because you're for people who
don't know and you should definitely
follow Gotham chess you've been on this
you've covered it a lot and I'm sure if
anything comes out you'll cover it more
but you've been quite balanced and
thoughtful and kind of objective about
the whole thing yeah so the reason for
that is
I understand the power that I wield with
anything and if I say one sentence the
wrong way I might be sending 10 000
people or more to go do something yeah
and I hate that I want to present the
evidence and I want the video to end and
people go okay
I understand not I'm gonna go I'm gonna
go [ __ ] someone up yeah you know what I
mean like because that's and I also
believe that even if Han's even if Hans
is guilty
this goes all the way back
he's a human being yeah
and
you can argue that cheater's got to be
punished and you can argue that people
who do things wrong you shouldn't feel
any sort of compassion
but I would hate to have the whole world
pointing at their fingers at me the
entire world that I've known my entire
life and even if I if I messed up
there's still a world after chess there
might still even be a world in chess I
don't know but
that stuff it doesn't make me it doesn't
make me feel good to present all of the
circumstantial evidence in my videos and
start being like yeah it looks you know
so but at the same time you deeply care
about Chess and the chess community and
there's some sense where
was it you as a Magnus that said that
cheating poses an existential threat
I mean there is some aspect of Truth to
that which is like
you know we the chess is in a state
where Bots uh chess engines are much
better than humans yeah and we're living
in a world where technology becomes
easier and easier to integrate with with
human beings whether you put in some
orifice or elsewhere and that that does
pose a threat to um to our ability to
trust that a world champion is indeed a
world champion that somebody we think is
good is indeed good and so there is some
aspect to the ecosystem
that should punish cheating and perhaps
over punished cheating and the other
thing is
in sport you can take PDS and have
bigger muscles bigger better reaction
time but you still have to perform the
action in a successful way there is
still a chance you can lose
if you take Peds
maybe in some sports the gap between
non-ped and ped user is significantly
more noticeable but
in chess
if you cheat
you play God
yeah you decide when the game is over
you can fake bad moves
you can fake everything you can even if
you're cheating quote unquote the right
way you're gonna lose plenty of games
to avoid getting detected so you can
create Bots that are 2 800 like you can
also just not listen if you know all the
best moves but choose to play on your
own oh I made a mistake not a big deal
you could yes Bots are all at a
different level but if you were to cheat
that you you play God you can decide
when you make your move and when the
engine makes its movement if you know
the top four lines of the engine you
choose the fourth one so in hindsight
people will analyze your game and they
will go oh it wasn't perfect well no
[ __ ] only the stupid cheaters play the
top Engine line the whole game by the
way I'm not saying that this is what's
happening here but
but there's uh there's probably an
excitement to Playing God
to to and get in the way with it like I
know people I know adults grown
adults who are successful in their
fields
and they they cheat they cheat in
lessons they cheat and like I've I don't
want to say I've taught any may I may or
may not have uh but for some reason one
of them watches this and they know
they're guilty uh and it happens it
happens uh not just teenagers not just
young adults but full-grown adults will
cheat when they play because it but I
think it helps them learn oh uh well
that's exactly just that's justification
but I just meant like I'm it might not
be just about winning
it might also just feel good to have
that power
like I bet you it's a drug oh yeah I
mean like with a lot of criminals
with a lot of criminals I feel like part
of like the mat like Mass murderers
would be serial killers I feel like a
lot of it is that can get away with it
the the fact that they
like they like everyone else is a sucker
and they figured out how to do this evil
thing
and uh obviously cheating is nowhere
close to that but but there's still a
feeling of getting away with it yeah I
wonder
and you're pretty objective on the whole
thing like where if you were
um a betting man what would you say is
the probability
and are you changing day by day in your
head what's the probability that Hans
cheated
over the board against Magnus in the in
St Louis that's a tough one man
have you even allowed yourself to to put
a probability on it no not on that
specific game because I think a lot of
that game was affected by magnus's own
psyche that was one of his worst games
ever so he played poorly to a Magnus
blade which doesn't help his case yeah
Hans might have cheated then that game
but we'll never know I
I think day by day
the evidence is slowly starting to show
more and more that
he's cheated it like like how Magnus
said more than he said and more recently
it's undeniable like right a lot of the
statistics are there the problem is
you can't prove you're not cheating
yeah unless you strip naked like that
site offered him a million bucks to like
everything about the which site
headline that said Hans Neiman bucks
and where I struggle to comprehend is
how on Earth he could pull it off
and
like I'm a guilty that my brain goes to
guilt first and resent yeah resentment
remorse guilt that kind of that Trio uh
Magnus put out a statement as we speak
yesterday saying dear Chess World at the
2022 sinkfield cup I made the
unprecedented professional decision to
withdraw from the tournament after my
round three game against Hans Neiman
a week later during the Champions chess
tour I resigned against Hans Neiman
after playing only one move I know that
my actions have frustrated many in the
chess Community I'm frustrated I want to
play chess I want to continue to play
Chess at the highest level in the best
events I believe that cheating in chess
is a big deal and an existential threat
to the game I also believe that chess
organizers and all those who care about
the sanctity of the game we love should
seriously consider increasing security
measures and methods of cheat detection
for over-the-board chess when Neiman was
invited last minute to the 2022
sinkfield cup I strongly considered
withdrawing prior to the event I
ultimately chose to play that's the
thing you're referring to is that he can
like now we know he was torn about the
whole thing I believe that Neiman has
cheated more and more recently than he
has publicly admitted
his over-the-board progress has been
unusual and throughout our game and
singfield cup I had the impression that
he wasn't tense or even fully
concentrating on the game in critical
positions while outplaying me as black
in a way I think only a handful of
players can do this game contributed to
changing my perspective
he must do we must do something about
cheating and for my part going forward I
don't want to play against people that
have cheated repeatedly in the past
because I don't know what they're
capable of doing in the future there's
more than I would like to say
unfortunately at this time I'm limited
in what I can say without explicit
permission from Neiman to speak openly
so
far I have only been able to speak with
my actions and those actions have stated
clearly that I am not willing to play
chess with Neiman I hope that the truth
in this matter comes out whatever it may
be sincerely Magnus Carlson
World chess champion
um I was used to know if your statements
if I was a world yeah no just say
whatever Lex Friedman what would be the
title yeah I don't know I think I would
not
even if I was a world champion I would
just say Lex
or make up a title
and I feel like I really [ __ ] up in
life if I have to tweet a statement as
an image that's like when you get
you've you're a politician you got
caught cheating on your wife
like for many years in a row yes then I
tweet an image I'm sorry for all the
people I have hurt and the people that
believed in me
and what whatever else and then I would
sign World chess champion you know the
most like the the modern way to give a
statement what I thought Magnus was
going to do yeah I thought he was gonna
write
on the recent
Scandal or my statement on the past few
weeks twit longer
what do you mean so you put a URL oh
yeah so that's for tweets but it's
unlimited characters it's not a hundred
I didn't know what that is can you
explain that to me yeah so generally
when a celebrity has a giant audience on
Twitter they will make their statement
on social media and say what it is in a
sentence yeah one line and then there's
a link where's the link take you it's a
website called twit longer oh there's
like tweet longer twit longer yeah and
that is where they write their
statements that is what I was expecting
I did this I haven't seen this before oh
this this is I don't have one off the
top of my head but it's just that Kanye
Kim Kardashian breaking up that would
use that streamers musicians yeah I
don't think politicians use it because
that it's just feeling yeah
Myspace and Facebook right uh yeah
I'll probably go see I I like um
I mean I'm not just being biased here
just because I have a podcast I'm a huge
fan of podcasts I feel like I would go
on a podcast to talk about it with
somebody I trust so like long form and
discuss it